You always want to outwork
Your potential as hard as you believe you can work you can work harder than that
And I had a summer where I played basketball when I was like 10 or 11 years old and yeah come
Playing and I don't score one point
The entire summer really not one if you got to get up every single morning
Remind yourself how hard you need to work? I need to choose a different profession
The motivation watch a top 10 with believe nation, what's that belief nation? That's Evan
I believe in you and this channel is designed to be a part of your daily success routine
So let's get your motivation to attend and get you believing in you grab a snack and chew in today's lessons from remain. Whoo
I'm from being a terrible
basketball player at age 10 and not being able to score a single point in the summer league to becoming one of the greatest NBA
basketball players of all time and winning five NBA
Championships is Kobe Bryant. And here's my take on his top. Ten rules a success vol 3
Okay, let's kick it off with rule number one have a champions mentality when I played
One of the things that had to learn is how to get the best out of my teammates
Yeah, and most people think it's a simple thing, you know passing the ball, you know
That's not how you make guys better. You have to really affect their behavior. How do you do that?
So yeah, like I would tell guys
You got it back to backs, you know, I don't care for in Miami
I don't care if we're in a great city of Chicago
You can't go out got your rest right back to back games second bag gets right monday-tuesday
You play Monday and play in Tuesday guys. I'm gonna listen right? You don't you're right
So few times said, all right, we'll all go out
Go out together, really I'll drink with you, right but the next morning I'm banging on your door at 5:00 in the morning
Let's go
They're not going. Where are we going? I'll hung out with you. Now you come hang out with me
This is what we do. All right, let's go. You're at the gym
We're working out right we hit the bus we go to practice we play that night and they're dead and they're dead
They're like lesson learned lesson learned take them out. Once listen, if you're gonna do that do that
But don't let that compromise we're here to do right? This is why we're here
This is why you're here in the first place Yeah, right and if we're gonna win a championship
We have to have that championship mentalis it work ethic. That's it
So you got to show them low coke can do that and still has the energy to get up and do this?
So either I gotta meet that same energy or I got to keep my but I'm gonna matter early. Yeah
rule number two
Outwork your potential I think the best way to prove your value is to work
Is to learn is to absorb
To be a sponge you
Always want to outwork
Your potential, you know as hard as you believe you can work you can work harder than that
And that's what I try to do when I first came and lead but you know basketball is such a direct competition sport
That me coming in at 17
I needed when like my teammates would say, you know, I get hit with an elbow right shack with it
they would elbow in practice and like
You know, it big bad actor will come up and say are you okay?
What?
The ma are you okay?
How would you know it's so like I always had that extra chip on my shoulder
So like every day I practice for me was really trying to annihilate everybody
That was that I was playing against because I wanted to prove you don't need to babysit me. Like I'm fine, you know and
and so as always
That competitive nature
the work ethic and
Curiosity because I asked a lot of questions, you know playing with Barnes God. I asked him a lot of questions
Eddie Jones who was great at chasing guards off the screens and I didn't understand how to do that
I would sit with him before practice after practice
Magic
James Worthy Kurt Rambis
Kareem Abdul all the Laker grades
I would always sit down and just asking questions about certain games that I've studied growing up. What actually happened there
What did you filled it and why you know bird tough to defend why cuz you look slow to me
I'm up like I'm missing something. So like tell me what I'm missing
You know what I think and so I would always ask questions and try to learn as much as I could
rule number three learned from failures
You talk about this often and we always talk about the fact that
You can learn a lot more from the failures and you can from the successes
and you have to figure out where those landmines are and
Then how to best avoid those or put or help entrepreneurs and ourselves included
Figure out the clues of where those land mines are not that you're going to avoid all of them
But it's also when you do step on one figure it out. Okay, how do you recuperate?
How do you balance back and you know pick yourself up rule number four be a long-term thinker I had a summer
Oh
I play basketball when I was like 10 or 11 years old and a very prominent some really good Philadelphia called the Sunny Hill week
My father played my uncle played every like all-time great stuff and Bo Chamberlain played in league
or other Perlman role-playing we've
become
Playing and I don't score one point
The entire summer really not one
How old were you 11 10 11?
You're playing against other 10 11 year-old sort and you didn't score once not one. Were you in the game?
I was in a game. How'd you not score? That was terrible? Really? Yeah that
Had a number years old you were that awful
I mean, I you know
and I had these big knee pads on because I'm wrong we fast I have socks all the way up here and I had like
The pod tops pity yeah, like skinny as hell and I scored not a free throw. Not a nothing not a lucky shot
Not a breakaway layup zero points. Is that when you think the mentality of hard work?
Started to come in for you at that age when you failed. So miserably, I guess that's somewhere
I think that's when the idea of
Understanding a long-term view became important because I wasn't gonna catch these kids in a week
I wasn't gonna catch him in a year, right? So that's why I said down. It's okay. This is gonna take some father
Alright, we'd all want to work on first. All right shooting. All right, let's knock this out
Let's focus on this half a year six months do nothing, but shoot right after that
All right, creating your own shot and you focus
So you start I started creating a menu of things when I came back the next summer
I was a little bit better right many be like, I've got my jump shot from 15 of God
Yeah, I got my job in 15
I got my three-point shot like just open shots not miss open shots
Right and be able to shoot it with speed because those kids are so much more athletic
Yeah, and then the next time I came back as a little better the summer came back. It was a little bit I scored
Yeah, it wasn't much but I scored 12 13 12 13 and then 14 came around back half of 13 14
Years old and then I was just killing everyone and it happened in two years and I wasn't expecting to happen in two years
But it did because what I had to do was work on the basics and the fundamentals
while they relied on an athletics ISM and their natural ability and
Because I stick to the fundamentals it just caught up to him and then my body, you know
my knees stopped hurting I grew into my frame and
And then your athleticism once you have the fundamental exactly the hard work the mindset and you tack on the 11
It was game Wow. So from 13 you're
Good average still that was good. That was good about about like the end of my 30 like right when I was turning 14
I became best clear in the state a 14 or 14. So I'm from 12 to 14
You went from scoring zero to being the best in the state of all ages. Yep
rule number five find your passion
We talked about hard work all the time mistake, you know, man
If you got to get up every single morning remind yourself how hard you need to work your I need to choose a different profession
You know because that shouldn't be there is that I wake up in the morning excited to get to it, you know
If I'm not training, I'm missing it. I'm not watching a game of bass. I miss it
I you know, there's no place
I'd rather be and if you have that feeling then you're truly doing with
God has put you on this earth to do rule number six
Challenge yourself to grow you were quoted in on CNBC as saying that you'd rather be remembered for your role in jump-starting tech companies
Than your skills on the court. Can you talk to the but what's that about it?
I think you have to challenge yourself to
Evolve and to grow and I think I couldn't think of a better message for you know athletes in particular
Because it's it's very easy for us a athletes to kind of lose ourselves
And our identity by connecting who we are to what we do
and I think that's a very dangerous zone to be in right so it's uh, it's
Common sense to me to be able to say okay the next stage
I'm going after with the same intensity same attention to detail the same curiosity
so, of course I'd want to be better at that than I was in my
Previous career. There's a pretty high bar there you have you have enough energy left for that orange
I guess we're gonna find out right
I mean that best thing
You know you go for it
And you do all you can you learn as much as you can't you continue to try to continue to improve you continue to evolve
The agency where you are, right?
you know 20 years from now you can like to look at the mirror and say I gave it my best shot and
we did the best we could and
See where we end up rule number seven. Keep going. There's a quote from
my English teachers alo Marian named
Mr. Fisk
He had a great quote that said rest at the end not in the middle
And that's something I always live by
You know
I'm not gonna rest I'm gonna keep on pushing now a lot of answers and I don't have even questions that I don't have
I'm just going to keep going
It's gonna keep going and I'll figure these things out as you go
Right and you just continue to build that way so I try to live by that all the time the rest at the end
Rest at the end rule number eight protect your dreams
Dreams is a they should be pure I think a lot of times we're born into this world. We actually wind up going backwards
And it seems like the more we mature
the more responsible our dreams become and the more Governors we put on ourselves and our ability to dream and
To reimagine and it's always a fight for his parents and for you guys to make sure that your dreams always stay pure
so it's not a matter of
Pushing beyond the limitations of expectations
It's really a matter of protecting your dreams protecting your imagination
that's really the key and when you do that in the world just seems
limitless rule number nine be driven my journey began in
Philadelphia, Pennsylvania
At the age of three years old my father putting a basketball my hands and me taking it from there
Basketball was in Kobe's blood his dad is Joe. Jellybean, Brian
He played eight years in the NBA before uprooting his family to take his career overseas as I grew older. We moved to Italy
While Joe was getting used to playing in Europe. His son was also making an adjustment in Italy
not many kids were perfecting a jump shot, but Kobe Bryant was
Soccer was a big sport. So he had goalposts underneath the baskets on
concrete courts
Were kids used to play soccer all day and I would be one of them and then after soccer I'd stay there for another three
Four or five hours his playing basketball
It was a different country with a different language
Even though he had his family he was essentially alone
So Kobe looked him and developed the relentless drive to work on his game
When his family moved back to Philadelphia that time spent alone on the court paid off as
Kobe announced his arrival to the basketball world. He was the top high school player in the country
breaking Wilt Chamberlain scoring records becoming a celebrity at 16
Kobe's next step may have seen damn Bish's but with his basketball pedigree and work ethic. It was an easy decision
Yeah and rule number 10 the last home before a very special bonus clip is achieve greatness
I remember season one you said who is this kid? It's 20th season
Only various careers in basketball will not allow them to be what do you want water any longer?
No one understand what it takes to be great
The force that drives you to do what others don't
The sacrifice is made
all with one purpose in mind
Push yourself to become better
The extra seconds minutes hours of work put into perfecting ones game
Lifting yourself above the rest
To make sure your name will forever be synonymous with one greatness
What does it take to be great work at the combination drive takes ability
It takes its desire they learn moves on muscle again turns it
I think it takes years of players
Relying on you to take the big shot make the great play, you know do the things that bring success to the team
That's that's what it's all about
Is getting out and measure yourself against others and I think that when you have an attitude like that
That's what I think that's part of greatness
The first time met Kobe Kobe was just out of high school
He was out here poor workup and I've never seen anyone work out this hard
This is coated. I've never seen anybody that prepared. He was 17 years old and was ready to play NBA basketball
That's that's pretty amazing. And I think Jerry West was
The one who said this he said I want this kid because this kid had more talent than anybody
I have a plan for me right now
And he had a great team
Just kidding would never take a night off even if it wasn't calling well it was always going to be trying to
Slay the dragon. If you don't have that type of work ethic you don't get to enjoy the benefits
Now I've got a special bonus clip from Kobe on how to be a good team player that I think you're gonna really enjoy but
before that it's time for the three-point landing questions time to move from just watching another video to actually taking
Action in your life or your business and if you're feeling bold leave your answers in the comments below
Here we go. Question number one. What is your big dream number two?
How will you protect it when people say that you can't do it and number three?
How will you keep going when you're not getting results?
When you're in this culture in our society you can do some phenomenal things individually
But they'll never reach their full potential
Unless you do them collectively. You have to figure out how to do that. And you know, Phil Jackson was great at then Phil
He wouldn't just coach the team or coach the game, but he'd read everything about every single player
We heard about your history. How you grew up
How you were raised where we were were you raised, you know, he'll read every interview
and he'll learn about you and
Gives him a better
understanding of what's motivating you
Or what your insecurities are right and then it just helps him communicate with you better
Or even push a button here if he needs to there was a stretch
and
o3
where Shaq was out with an injury and
Phil called me up to his office and said okay
We need you to really turn on the afterburners to start scoring or you have to win. So I
Did and I wound up scoring. I think it was nine straight games for 40-plus points
Nine straight - three games and then Shaq comes back
Second it's second to last game of that. And then Phil calls me up to his office is cold
Okay, I need you to dial it back
I'm like
Why I like well, how about I understand is because our goal is to win a championship. Mmm and
We can get through the Western Conference with you playing this way
But in the East, you know, we can dominate them inside with Shaq in the post
But if you continue to do this, we'll lose Shaq will lose him his motivation his exciting what triggers him right?
So I need you to pull back
so we can pull Shaq forward for June and I just looked at him like
Smart dude. Wow. Yeah, this is what smart dude man sigh pull pulled it back
See once was
Yeah, the most important work ever if you had to think of one word
That's most important to you or that sums you Apple. That would be connect a little beacon
If you want more Kobe check with the first top 10 video ident under him
The link is right there next to me
I think you'll enjoy it continue to believe and I'll see you there. We have to make as people as individuals
So if you want to be great at something
You have to make the inherit sacrifices that come along with that family time